-Congratulations
on your Broadway debut.
-Thanks, man.
-This is -- This would not be
that surprising for people
you've known your whole life.
You were -- You did a lot
of theater growing up.
-Yeah, yeah,
big, big theater kid.
-Did you do
any of the big plays?
-Name one.
I probably did it, yeah.
-"West Wide Story"?
-I was Action.
-Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
So this is not --
And how do you feel --
How's the work of doing a play
compared to doing a movie?
-Compared to doing a movie?
I mean, well --
You know, a lot of movies, you
don't always get rehearsal time.
Sometimes you -- you know,
you shake an actor's hand,
and then
you're doing a scene with him.
So with a play,
there's a lot more
rehearsal time, a lot more prep.
It's -- I don't know.
It's a lot nicer.
That's why I wanted to do it.
Just to kind of feel a different
way in to what I do.
-Is it exhausting?
-It is.
I mean,
everyone that I talked to,
a lot of my actor buddies
were like,
"Ah, your whole day is free.
It's only two hours
at the theater."
But it's two hours.
It's such a focused two hours.
You leave the theater,
and you're spent.
You just want to go back to bed.
-I want to ask
about your mustache.
[ Laughter ]
-Also, I noticed --
-I'm surprised you got a couple
questions in without asking.
-Well, I didn't want
to make you think
it's the only reason
I wanted you here.
-I have a mustache.
Let's just get it out there.
-We tried to book your mustache.
[ Laughter ]
They said the only way
it could come was with you.
-He's very choosey, yeah.
-But I noticed as I was
holding up the playbill,
you didn't have it here.
Was this a late decision?
-So...
Maybe I shouldn't be saying --
So, when I was filming --
We were filming "Avengers"
in Atlanta last year.
And they said,
"Well, they want to come
and do a photo shoot
for the play."
And I said, "Well, I'm not gonna
look the way I want to look."
And they said,
"Ah, it doesn't matter."
It's not like -- I don't know.
I guess that's the way it is.
It's okay if the photos look
different from how you look.
And I said, "No, I'm gonna look
very different.
I know it's just a mustache,
but it changes my whole face."
-But we were talking backstage.
It does change your whole face,
which might be helpful
for being recognized.
Has it been easier
to walk around with it?
-Oh, yeah. I can look people
dead in their eyes...
[ Laughter ]
Not only do they
not recognize me,
you get some strange --
you get a little, like --
You got mustache profiled.
-This mustache and this haircut,
I feel, like,
gives us a lot of back story
about who you are.
-Now what would I be?
It's either a cop or...?
What else would I be?
-A guy who tried to be a cop
and failed the test
and is super mad about it.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you're hoping for cop.
-See, I was gonna say something
along the lines of porn.
-Yeah.
-And I always thinks so --
But it's so strange.
That's the typical response.
-The funny thing --
-And it's strange
that those two things, like,
live on the same street.
How is it, like,
cop, porn actor?
-Yeah.
-Like, those are --
- And when a cop shows up in
a porno, it's like a perfect --
That's when it's like, yeah.
-Nailed it.
The weird thing is Steve Rogers,
Captain America, of course,
like, this looks way more
like most "Steve Rogers,"
I think.
[ Laughter ]
Like, most guys named
Steve Rogers look like this.
-Look like this guy.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show --
I know it's hard for all
of you guys who are
in these big movies.
You can't tell me
anything about it.
This is spoiler city.
-Oh, yeah. I got nothing.
-64 characters in this film.
-Yeah.
-Let's show a clip and see
if I can get any information.
-Give it a shot.
-When you said
we were going to open Wakanda
to the rest of the world,
this is not what I imagined.
-And what did you imagine?
-Well, the Olympics.
Maybe even a Starbucks.
♪♪♪♪
[ Air hissing,
gangway motor whirring ]
-Should we bow?
-Yeah. He's a king.
-Seems like I'm always
thanking you for something.
-[ Clears throat ]
-What are you doing?
-We -- We don't do that here.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
I don't know much about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean,
I have one line in the clip.
[ Laughter ]
Like, typically, when you come
to a thing like this,
you bring something
to showcase, whatever.
-Yeah.
-But they sent me the clip,
and I was like, "Is this what
I'm bringing to 'Seth Meyers'?"
'Cause everything I'm in
is some form of a spoiler.
-So you have one.
And every talk show you go on,
you're like, "Keep an eye on
the way I walk off the plane."
[ Laughter ]
"I made a very interesting
choice in my de-planing."
-A lot of preparation.
-You -- Obviously,
you play Captain America.
You get a lot of action figures.
This one --
They sent us a bunch.
This one's my favorite...
-God.
-...because of this.
Ready?
Have you seen this yet?
-No.
-Oh. Sorry.
Hold on.
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
See? It changes expressions.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's like the, uh --
-Yeah.
-Happy.
-Medium.
-Wait.
What was the middle expression?
-Wait. I want to --
I got a plan here.
-[ Chuckles ]
He's defacing my character.
-Well, let's do --
Hold on. Wait.
All right, there we go.
How would you describe it?
This is angry. Right?
-Yeah, angry.
-Okay, there we go.
That's happy dude, right?
-That's mustache.
[ Laughter ]
That's porn-star guy.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, he looks --
He looks ready to go, too.
-This guy,
he's very ready to go.
And how did it go afterwards?
Oh, he's angry.
It didn't go well.
Oh, now he's better.